Republicans believe they're in prime
position to pick up a US Senate seat in
Indiana this fall but they're trying to
make sure the primary campaign brings
out the right candidate to take on
incumbent Democrat Joe Donnelly in
November correspondent Peter Doocy tells
us it's all about which man is the
closest thing to President Trump to save
a blue seat in deep red Indiana
Democratic Senator Joe Donnelly is
appealing to voters who want to make
America great again
sometimes I've voted with the president
62 percent of the time voted for justice
Korsak we've worked together on the
opioid issue we've worked together in
veterans issues he was a know on tax
reform even though Donnelly was warned
about what no would mean we will come
here we will campaign against him like
you wouldn't believe
the president's help is seen as
priceless two Republican primary
candidates here because he beat Clinton
by 19 points in 2016 with the state's
former governor on the ticket and
benefited from glowing endorsements by
two of the state's most beloved coaches
Bobby Knight and Lou Holtz now one
contender congressman Todd Roe Kida says
he's supported the president longer than
congressman Luke Messer who once
suggested Trump could be replaced his
nominee at the RNC convention if you
didn't believe in him if you know during
the campaign then you're not really
gonna believe in him now roki de says
Messer his former Wabash College
classmate is the wrong choice we're a
different kettle of fish
he is establishment Messer disagrees
arguing roki de can't be the greater
Trump Ally because he just voted against
his budget my opponent he talks Trump
Trump Trump but when it's time to show
courage and vote for president Trump's
agenda votes no no no a third GOP
challenger businessman Mike Braun is
using cardboard cutouts to highlight
similarities between Roe kita and Messer
where do you think they live
Washington one of them does Messrs wife
and kids live in Virginia and the out of
state residency raises questions similar
to those that doomed longtime incumbent
Senator Richard Lugar in the 2012
primary I've got a home in Indiana that
I've owned for 17 years my kids do need
a full-time father but I'll tell you
this that's not what Hoosiers are
focused on whichever Republican wins
will face a rare kind of Democrat in
Donnelly I've tried not to serve as
either a Democrat or a Republican
senator but as a Hoosier Senator I just
spoke to a state GOP official who tells
me that Donnelly is vulnerable and it's
not a cakewalk to beat him but they're
confident that no matter who wins this
Republican primary that person will
become the next senator from Indiana and
there is no concern at the state level
at this point about the infighting
instead the party sees it as a way to
get damaging information out ahead of
the general Chris Peter Doocy reporting
from Indiana Peter thank you